[Music]
spirit therefore
here appears as an artificer and it's
action whereby it produces itself as
object but without
having yet grasped the thought of itself
is an instinctive operation like the
building of a honeycomb by
bees
paragraph 691 is now going to lead us
into the third part of the natural
religion sub-section of this
you know penultimate religion section
of the work natural religion itself is
not that long there's important stuff
happening in there but
you could say from a hegelian
perspective it's not as important
in part because not as developed as what
is going to be happening
in the subsequent to subsections
religion
the religion of art or religion through
art and then
revealed religion so here we're dealing
with
as hegel is going to say here something
that's
instinctual or instinctive
instinct artigas and we'll talk about
that in a moment it's just not
as a fully developed thought in the full
sense is not
as in involved here
and you know we might say well who does
hegel have in mind
when we're talking about um you know
what we've got translated here is the
artificer
or religion as the product
of the artificer the vichmeister
and you know one strong suggestion is
well we're talking about
basically everything that's not the
greeks or
judaism and and christianity and doesn't
fall into the other sections earlier
like you know zoroastrianism with the
religion of light and there's something
to that
right others say what he really has in
mind here
is egyptian religion where there is a
strong focus on
developing statuary developing
shapes you know think about the pyramids
and other
things well the sphinx right so you know
he's not he's going to tell us about a
few parts of this but
it's it's actually still remaining
rather abstract so i think
it's important that we turn to looking
at the determination
that spirit is taking on here so you
know if we look
back at the the previous paragraph right
he's talking about productive activity
not a perfect but conditioned activity
the fashioning of a material
ready to hand that's where we're getting
this instinctive
operation that that's happening at the
very end of this
very short paragraph and you know
what does that mean that that there's a
less intentionality
spirit is by not engaging in
thought spirit is thinking but it's only
thinking about how can i use this stuff
that i have
you might even say ready at hand what
what i can quarry
in this immediate area or get brought in
how can i fashion that
into the things that don't require me to
stretch my mind
quite as far to think about my own
working
as a worker right so he says
spirit appears as an
artificer a varick meister and it's
worth dwelling on the distinction that
you know is getting made here in the
text
vikmeister is not the same thing as
kunstler somebody who is making
artwork right and
in that case later on we're not just
going to be talking about statuary but
also like
poetry and so there's a number of
different media
in which artwork can take place um
the virk the you know the working
of some material into an
object that is from a hegelian
perspective
less developed it's it's lower right
it's still
the pinnacle for certain civilizations
in terms of what what we have
you know in terms of religion but it's
it's not that
important so he says uh it appears as an
artificer it's action
the action of production
by which it produces itself as object
but without yet having yet grasped the
thought
of itself right so it's not as
self-aware it's not as reflective
it's not problematizing as we see for
example in epic poetry the nature of
epic poetry itself it's just doing
the things that it does so in this
section we're going to have these
various kinds of doings going on that
are essentially determined by
what kind of workers we have what kind
of masters of of the working
we have and what materials and then what
conceptions they have
in mind to exploit so we get an object a
gergenstand
which allows spirit to be able to
picture itself to itself
and we we should pause here and think
well okay
is the only person who's religious the
person who's fabricating say
idols no obviously it's the people who
value them and the people who use them
in their worship
and carry them from place to place so
it's not just the worker but the worker
is kind of like
an emblem and we could say it's less
about the worker him or herself
and more about what they're able to
produce the object
now this instinctive operation right in
instinct arctic is our bitin
our bitin you know there's labor
involved in this
instinct artigas of the sort that is
instinct
driven or instinct determined rather
than
deliberately thought through obviously
you know
if there's a statue that's being
produced of a god
and it's uniting human and animal forms
or if there's some geometry involved in
the construction of an
obelisk or a pyramid it's not totally
instinctual like as hegel says you know
bees making honeycombs but there is
something
like that going on it's you could say
conditioned thought it's not going
anywhere near as far
as the artistic production that we're
going to see later on
goes
the first form because it is immediate
is the abstract form of the
understanding and the work is not yet in
its own self
filled with spirit the crystals of
pyramids and obelisks simple
combinations of straight lines with
plain surfaces and equal proportions of
parts in which
the incommensurability of the round is
destroyed
these are the works of this artificer of
rigid form
on account of the merely abstract
intelligibleness
of the form the significance of the work
is not in the work itself
is not the spiritual self thus
either the for the works receive spirit
into them only as an alien departed
spirit
that is forsaken its living saturation
with reality and
being itself dead takes up its abode in
this lifeless crystal
or they have an external relation to
spirit
as something which is itself there
externally
and not as spirit they are related to it
as to the dawning light which casts its
significance
on them
in paragraph 692 hegel is now
going to begin walking us through
more specific shapes they are still
quite general but more specific
shapes that the religion of the
artificer
is taking on and then what this means is
ways in which spirit
is coming to understand itself
you know not completely as a matter of
fact not even halfway we can say
in this but you know it's getting to
something
more developed on the way so here we're
actually talking about the very first
though so don't expect
an awful lot out of this and he tells us
that this is immediate right on
unmediated
and it's the abstract form of the
understanding so you know whenever
something is abstract for hegel
it's a starting point or it's the
product of
a process of abstraction and and we
should mention too that for hegel
you see this running throughout the rest
of his works and this is part of german
idealism
more broadly there is a distinction
between the understanding
right for stand and reason a higher
faculty fair nuanced and
the understanding does things in ways
that don't make it to the point of of
fairness right of reason
so conceptual understanding is not
something that's really
available instead it's it's you know
what he's been calling for stellang
representation picture language however
you want to
frame it that is uh germaine to the
understanding in the lectures on the
philosophy of religion hegel makes this
you know crystal
clear crystal clear being kind of a pun
here because we're
soon going to be talking about crystals
and and by the way not the crystals
of new agey sort of stuff although maybe
hegel would consider that
in some respects a reversion back to
this but
but you know other types of crystalline
structures
and so we've got this abstract form of
the understanding and what it's going to
do
is use its own concepts and categories
to project
something onto reality as that which is
to be
made that which is to be fashioned
worked upon
so he tells us that this is the abstract
form of the understanding the work is
not
yet in its own self filled with spirit
this is really the key
point of this paragraph
and indeed of this this section itself
as we're going to see in the paragraphs
yet to come so there is this process of
production and what are we producing
as the religious objects things that
have the shapes of crystals
and what's characteristic of crystals
other than you know looking really cool
because they're
colorful usually right there isn't any
discussion of color here it's really
about
shape it's about making geometry
happen in nature now with crystals
geometry or geometrical simple shapes
are happening in nature you know usually
not like super simple shapes we're not
usually getting
just uh four-sided figures any of you
who are
you know remembering tabletop role
playing and the many sided dice right
you have a four-sided die which is
really a pyramid
then you can have you know the cube
six-sided
and you can have eight-sided and
ten-sided and twelve-sided and
twenty-sided
you can even find like a hundred-sided
die which really approximates to a ball
in many respects um well all of those
things are
are essentially crystalline shapes
they're solids that represent something
and so the human being as a worker is
now
producing those as artistic objects and
not just in handicraft
but on a huge scale so you know when
we're talking about pyramids
and you know we do see pyramids in many
cultures and you know
it's interesting a bit of a side note
some people have been like
wow that must mean that they all learned
from each other
some common stock or maybe aliens came
down
no pyramids are a fairly
simple way to stack bricks
and then to make a shape you know a
ziggurat is a kind of pyramid
uh that that's sort of a step temple
that we find
in mesopotamia the pyramids that we find
in mesoamerica
those in egypt right all of these are
feasible
because these reflect certain things
that we human beings can figure out how
to do it doesn't require that you
learned it from you know some god-like
alien or anything like that or that you
you know had some weird cultural
transmission that is you know
historically
implausible so we we make these
crystalline things
and like hegel says you know what's
really characteristic of these and
how does this tie in with the
understanding there's two
characteristics
these have simple combinations of
straight lines
with plain surfaces and equal proportion
of parts it's a way in which we
introduce
geometry into the world
that we're experiencing right and
now this is a little funny because we
could say well there are circles hegel's
saying that this is a deviation from the
incommensurability
of roundness but you know we might think
about you know
uh stone circles right but
let's put that aside because maybe hegel
didn't have that sort of thing in mind
so he says that um these are the works
of this artificer of rigid
form so there's no
tension in these there's no
dynam you know dynamic way of framing
them
there's no you know pulling the eye in
and producing some sort of effect they
just are what they are right they're
very
simple and straightforward even though
they may require a lot of
labor and they are they are indeed
a um a result of human activity they are
indeed a shape of spirit they are indeed
an advance over nothing right so let's
not
knock them all together but they don't
provide spirit
you could say with a adequate vehicle
for understanding itself so here he
tells us on account of the merely
abstract
intelligibleness of the form right being
able to understand it the
intelligibleness understanding you
should understand those as going
together the significance of the work is
not in the work itself
that's a problem the significance of the
work the meaning of the work
is not in what has been produced
so in a way this is going to be an
interesting progression but
it's going to be also a a bit of a dead
end
so he tells us you know this there it's
not the spiritual
self why not well there's two different
possibilities
so either the works receive spirit
in them only as an alien departed spirit
or he jumps ahead and says they're
related to it as the dawning
light right so neither of these is
really going to be
what we want but they are ways in which
uh you know early human beings were able
to
understand themselves in relation to the
religious objects so
like he says here's the first option um
they receive spirit into themselves as
only an
alien departed spirit
that has forsaken its living saturation
with reality
and being itself dead right
inert passed on
it takes up its abode in this lifeless
crystal
so we might think of you know in terms
of the pyramid um the resting place for
the pharaoh who is like a god on earth
you know
surrounded by all sorts of illuminated
pictures of other gods he's joining them
or she's joining them whoever's joining
them
but they're dead and that's it there's
nothing
more that's going to happen there's
nothing that's going to move us
respond to us and at best we can hope to
like accompany the
pharaoh on their their journey um maybe
what would an obelisk preserve i mean
think about some of the ones that were
erected
to celebrate victories they keep
somebody's
memory their their great god-like deeds
alive yeah okay for a while
right until the next conqueror comes
around so he says
uh that's one possibility or they have
an external relation to spirit
as something which is there externally
and not as
spirit how can spirit not be spirit well
it's present in a way that doesn't do
justice to spirit and so he says
they're related to it as the dawning
light which casts its significance on
them this is a reference back to the you
know
religion of light and this is something
external so you've got the
nice uh religious artifacts here you
know
architecture and light get cast
on it allows you to see it but that's it
and so we're not getting
spirit in any significant sense through
this stage
the division from which the artificer
spirit starts the in itself which
becomes the material it fashions and the
being
for self which is the aspect of
self-consciousness at work
this division has become objective to it
in its work
its further efforts must aim at getting
rid of this division of soul and body to
clothe
and give shape to soul in its own self
and to endow body with
soul the two aspects in being brought
closer to each other
retain this
since the work in the coming together of
its aspects comes closer to itself
this at the same time produces another
result namely
that the work comes closer to the
self-consciousness
performing it and that the latter in the
work comes to know
itself as it is in its truth
but in this way the work at first
constitutes only the abstract
aspect of the activity of spirit which
does not yet know the content
of this activity within itself but in
its work which is a thing
the artificer himself spirit in its
eternity has not yet appeared
but is the still inner hidden essence
which
as an entirety is present only as
divided into
active self-consciousness and the object
it has produced
paragraph 693 is going to get us past
the
sterility of this this first
dependence upon geometric form
as the object that the the artifice or
the varek meister
is creating for centering
spirit in religion and we're going to
see that there's now
two key sides that are being
brought together and perhaps even
reconciled
in religious production
worship however we want to conceive of
this
but we have to be very careful what's
happening
here is in some respect a
looking ahead to the section yet to come
and hegel's laying it out and then
saying oop
that's not happening yet so you know
very very typical
hegel move so let's take a look at what
he says there's there's this division
right and this is not a a distinction an
intershead right this is instead a
separation out of two things the
division from which he says the
artificer spirit
starts now artificer spirit is how
miller
is translating a little bit fast and
loose
are biting the geist now it's true that
it is the varkmeister
the artificer who is carrying out the
labor
the r biten in this case and that this
is
spirit who is doing this through
the artificer but you know it's
so it's not wrong but it's it's a little
bit of a deviation here
so he says this division what is the
division into so
being in itself you know
on zeke signs which becomes the material
it fashions and
being for self physics signs which is
the aspect of self-consciousness at work
he says this division
has become objective to it in its work
so what does that mean for a division
or you know a separating out to become
objective to it it's been made into
something that it can it can visualize
it can see it can realize
it can conceptualize in the thing that
has been
created the the the work the virg
right the thing that the varek meister
engages in and that other people that
are going to
use as an object of religious devotion
worship
and conceptual approaches to
the deity so there's this division and
this may not be a division for the
worshipers maybe that's why hegel
doesn't talk about them at all
but it is for the person who is
fabricating whatever it's going to be
the statue
the architecture the pyramid the obelisk
all of those things are the matter
that is is being transformed so he tells
us
now here's where he gets an interesting
metaphor it its further efforts must aim
at getting rid of this division
now he doesn't say division of being in
itself and being for itself and now he
says
body and soul so
this is you know kind of an interesting
choice here especially since he's going
to also introduce another
distinction that goes along with this
between universal
and particular body and soul are not
universal in particular
are they um is
the material that's being fashioned the
body
in the sense of being a living organic
thing
and is the aspect of self-consciousness
at work the soul that's a little bit
easier right because yes the soul
understands itself the body doesn't
understand itself except through the
intermediary
of the soul but you know what we've
talked about here just a moment ago is
inert stuff
that could at best be inhabited by a
dead spirit
now we're getting living things so he
says
um to clothe and give shape to soul in
its own self endow body with soul we
want a reconciliation here each of them
needs something from the other and then
here he says the two aspects in being
brought closer to each other which is a
key you know idea here things are being
brought
closer they're being integrated with
each other
retain the specific character of spirit
as ideally conceived
and as it's enveloping husk so
body presumably is the enveloping husk
and
spirits unity uh the you know the spirit
is ideally conceived must be the soul in
this case and he tells us that spirit's
unity with itself contains now here's
where he says something a little weird
this antithesis gegenzotz of
universal and individual
which of them is universal well
is it the material thing that's not
really universal but in a way it is
universal you could have the same kind
of shape
or is it the aspect of
self-consciousness at work that sounds
more individual or individuated
does it not we'll put that off for just
a moment
so he says since the work
in this coming together of these aspects
comes closer to itself now that's an
interesting thing to say
it makes sense for the spirit to come
closer to itself it makes sense for
these things to come closer to
themselves
you know being brought into being
as the the thing but how does the thing
the work
the object of worship become closer to
itself
well because it does contain spirit
it is the result of spirit there's
something that's being found there
so he says the work comes closer to the
self-consciousness
performing it and the latter in the work
comes to know
itself as it is in its truth now that is
important once again we're not talking
about the community we're not talking
about the worshipers
we're talking about the artificer
coming to know who the artificer is
in the work that he or she does and
thereby
coming to know spirit as something that
could be worshipped so imagine
you know a statue producer who does see
the fact that
this is you know materials that they're
transforming
before they carve the wood into the
statue it's just
wood right and painted and all that and
they know their own
labor involved in it and the thought
that's going into it but it produces
something that's greater than that
it's almost like a pygmalium kind of
story isn't it
so he goes on and he tells us
here we go in this way the work at first
constitutes only the abstract
aspect of the activity of spirit which
does not yet know
the content of this activity within
itself but in its work which is a
thing the artificer himself
notice what he's saying the artificer
himself the worker
does know himself we've already
established that this is
self-consciousness at work
the artificer capital a or in this you
know the german
capital w uh although you know
it's already capitalized so maybe super
capital w
the worker that is spirit in its
entirety
has not yet appeared but is the still
inner hidden essence which is an
entirety
is present only as divided into active
self-consciousness
and the object it has produced which are
now still
present to each other in a
opposition
the surrounding habitation then the
outer reality which has been raised at
first
only into the abstract form of the
understanding
is fashioned by the artificer into a
more life-like form
for this purpose he employs plant life
which is no longer
sacred as it was to the earlier impotent
pantheism
on the contrary the artificer who grasps
himself
as the being that is for itself takes
that plant life as something to be used
and reduces it to an outer aspect to a
mere ornament
but it is not used unaltered for the
artificer of the self-conscious form
at the same time destroys the
transitorioness inherent in the
immediate existence of this life
and brings its organic forms nearer to
the more rigid
and more universal forms of thought
the organic form which left to itself
proliferates unchecked in particularity
being itself subjugated by the form of
thought
in turn raises these rectilinear flat
shapes into a roundness more typical of
the organic form
a blending which becomes the root of
free architecture
now in paragraph 694 we see some
new developments hegel is
having the artificer bring
in something other than just geometric
natural
objects which you know leave room for
religion of light
and this very simple sort of
architecture
and shapes and now we get organic forms
you notice here that hegel is in some
respects retracing the section that we
just went through
with plant and animal because in this
paragraph he's going to talk
about plants then in the next paragraph
it's going to be
animals so the artificer of eric meister
the person who produces the work
is now dealing with a similar
sort of thing that we saw in the last
paragraph a being
in itself a being for itself that are
brought together
the material and the you know work of
self-consciousness or if you like the
body
and the soul but it's happening in terms
of plant life and so he says
the surrounding habitation the outer
reality which has been raised into the
abstract form of the understanding
is fashioned by the artificer into a
more
lifelike form now that's that's
something worth thinking about
obviously the artificer is not creating
plant life
right he is only reproducing it he is
only
picturing it but it is something
new something uh to that that is
transforming the ways in which the
objects of religion the things that are
being fixated on
are being grasped and understood so it's
no longer worshipping plants
it's worshipping the images of plants
the foreshadowing
of of plants right so
he says for this purpose he employs
plant life and there's an important
transformation happening here it's no
longer
sacred as it was to the earlier impotent
pantheism so it's no longer the plants
as such
just by themselves that are sacred
now it's the essence of them the
representation of them what it is that
the vicmeister is able to
do with them and you notice that it's
not going to be just reproduction of
plants as such as if you know
in order to worship maize or the maize
god you have to like make the entire
plant structure and then
you know the ears of corn or something
like that no
there's going to be elements of it
aspects of it that
get incorporated and this is quite
important so he says
on the contrary the artificer grasps
himself
as the being that is for itself right
through through their activity
they take that plant life as something
to be used and they reduce it to an
outer aspect to a mere
ornament and ornamentation is going to
be one of the things
that happens so we could have you know
for example a pyramid
but we could have plant forms within the
the pyramid structure in some way
ornamentation now ornamentation
it's not affecting the the structure of
the thing itself
it's just like extra stuff that we're
putting on he says it's not used
unaltered
the artificer of the self-conscious form
at the same time
destroys the transitoryness inherent in
the immediate existence of this life
what does that mean plants die right
plants change over time
again if we want to use maize or corn
as an example um you know we have a
saying here
uh in in the midwest knee-high by the
fourth of july you know you want the
corn to be at least
knee-high or else you're not going to
have a very good harvest and then it
shoots up and it's you know
taller than me by the time that it's
fully grown and the tassels appear
and it starts pollinating and then
making the ears
it doesn't stay the same from day to day
i mean there's
there's an expression here it's so humid
you can hear the corn growing
right if that's the case then it's not
remaining
the same there's a transitoriness to it
by putting it into stone by putting it
into wood by putting it into artistic
reproduction
through paints we're holding it still
we're idealizing it you know think about
vines there's another prime example
right
you see that in a lot of artwork
throughout the ancient world
so he says we we destroy the
transitoriness and bring its organic
forms nearer
the more rigid and universal forms of
thought so
there's something going on here we're
using what we learned before
and now making things remain still
remain the same it says the organic form
which left to itself proliferates
unchecked in particularity being
subjugated by the form of thought
raises these rectilinear flat shapes
into a roundness more typical of the
organic form
a blending which becomes the root of
free architecture so
the the first stage where we're dealing
with these geometric forms
and plant life are being brought
together now
integrated into a kind of harmony that
yields us
first ornamentation then organic forms
and then provides us with the root of
what hegel is calling free architecture
so this is a very important second stage
of
transition in terms of the works that
are being produced by the
artificer
you